>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Elizabeth Peterson: My
name is Betsy Peterson.
I'm the Director of the American
Folklife Center here at the Library
of Congress, and on
behalf ot the staff I want
to welcome you all
today to the latest
in our Homegrown concert series.
And the Homegrown concert
series is an opportunity
for the American Folklife Center
to feature music that, or dance,
that is rooted in place,
rooted in community,
and rooted in shared
cultural traditions.
When we put on this series we work
throughout the year with networks
of folklorists, folk
arts coordinators,
other cultural specialists
throughout the United States
who help us identify the very best
traditional musicians and performers
to come and share their art and
culture with all of you and all
of us here in Washington, D.C.,
and we're all the better
for it I have to say.
One caveat before we
begin the concert.
One of the other things that's
nice about this series is
that it allows us to record
the music here, and the music
and the concerts here
become part of the Archive
of the American Folklife
Center so that it will make it
onto our website through webcasts
so people around the world can hear,
and for future generations to hear.
So with that said, if
you have a cell phone
or any other electronic
device, I would ask you
to turn it off right now.
And I also want to say that
as we work with folklorists
around the country we also
work with organizations here
to make this happen, and I do want
to acknowledge our co-sponsor today,
the National Council for
the Traditional Arts,
for helping to make this possible
and we really appreciate their help.
So, with that said, I'm not
going to bring up someone else
to tell you a little bit
more about the concert today,
and that is Cliff Murphy.
Cliff is formerly the Director of
the Program for Traditional Arts
at the Maryland Arts Council.
He is now the Director of the
Folk and Traditional Arts Program
at the National Endowment
for the Arts.
He's also, in his own right, a
musician, a country musician,
a rock musician, and all
sorts of other things.
He also has a degree
in Ethnomusicology
from Brown University.
But I'm going to bring
him out here right now.
Cliff, along with Henry
Glassie and Douglas Peach.
just did a wonderful,
wonderful book slash recording
that has just come out, Ola Belle
Reed and Southern Mountain Music
on the Mason-Dixon Line, and
I encourage you to look for it.
It's on Dust to Digital.
So, with that said, I want
to introduce Cliff Murphy.
[ Applause ]
>> Clifford Murphy:
Thank you, Betsy.
Hello, everybody.
How is everybody today?
Good? All right.
I hope you're excited to
hear some great music.
Are you, yes?
>> Yes.
>> Clifford Murphy:
All right, that's good.
Welcome to your lunch break.
My name's Cliff Murphy and I'm
very proud to be here today
to present today's group and
to introduce you to some folks
that I've had the pleasure
of working
with over the last seven years or
so leading up to, in some ways,
today's event and the
publication that has just come out,
Ola Belle Reed and
Southern Mountain Music
on the Mason-Dixon Line.
I've been involved here with
my friends and colleagues,
Henry Glassie and Doug Peach.
If you guys could wave [laughter].
My co-authors and fellow
adventurers.
And Alan Burdette who's
here from the Archive
of Traditional Music in Indiana.
It's been a great adventure.
For those of you -- how many
people here are familiar
with Ola Belle Reed?
There's a lot.
Okay. So for those of
you who don't know,
Ola Belle was really a remarkable
singer, songwriter, banjo player,
traditional musician,
country philosopher --
would you say that's a fair term?
-- who lived in Rising
Sun, Maryland.
Was originally from
Lansing, North Carolina.
Moved up to the Mason-Dixon
Line region of --
along the
Maryland/Pennsylvania/Delaware
border during the Depression with a
large wave of Appalachian migrants
who came up for good jobs
and good, cheap farmland,
and settled in the region.
Brought a lot of music with them.
Also brought other traditions, but
what has really kind of survived
in a lot of ways is the music.
And so Ola Belle passed away
a little over 10 years ago
but joining us today is her son,
David Reed, and two, let's see,
her nephew, Hugh Campbell.
There are also other
relatives in the house.
I know that there are members of the
Campbell family here today with us.
If you guys could wave.
I think there's quite a few of you.
So it's a real honor
to have you here today.
And we also have Alex
Campbell, Ola Belle's brother
and performing partner
for many years.
Alex's son, Rob, is here today.
It's great to have you with us.
And it's a funny thing
about this tradition.
So, Ola Belle and Alex started
a couple of country music parks
in Maryland and Pennsylvania,
and these became important stopping
points for a lot of musicians
that many of you may
have heard of --
people like the Stanley
Brothers, Bill Monroe.
Backstage we were talking
beforehand.
There's a picture of Dolly
Parton from when she performed
on this stage, and Rob, Alex
Campbell's son, was telling me
that his job used to be to interview
Dolly when she would come through
and play on the family's
radio program.
So it tells you a little
bit about the interactions
between these musicians who many
of us think of as local musicians,
and with kind of the
national stars and how
that was a very fluid
thing for a very long time.
And these traditions kind of pass
across these boundaries
of national/local music.
And also joining us today is I think
what we'd call a passel of Paisleys.
We have Danny Paisley,
Michael Paisley,
and Danny's son, Ryan,
who I think is 15?
Is that correct?
We'll just say yes.
Ryan plays mandolin.
And the Paisleys play a
brand of bluegrass music
that really blends honky-tonk,
country music traditions
with bluegrass, with old time music.
And they're joined by
fiddle player TJ Lundy.
There are a lot of ties
between all of these musicians
and the collections that are
here at the Library of Congress
and the American Folklife Center.
TJ's great-grand-uncle, Emmett
Lundy, was recorded by John
and Elizabeth Lomax a
little over 70 years ago,
and those recordings reside here.
And also, Ola Belle was
somebody who, and Alex,
were recorded by Mike Seeger.
And many of those recordings reside
here as well And then, or course,
Henry Glass's recordings
of Ola Belle, so --
which are included in this
[inaudible] digital release
that we hope you'll check out.
And enough about that.
I think that you're all here
for music instead of a lecture.
Is that right?
Did I get the memo?
Okay. So, if you would please
give a warm welcome to,
and I will introduce
them one-by-one,
Mr. Dave Reed on guitar and banjo.
[ Applause ]
You guys can start coming on out.
Mr. Hugh Campbell on guitar
and vocals and [applause].
Both of these guys will be playing
some of their original songs.
We also have Mr. Danny Paisley on
guitar and vocals, Michael Paisley,
his brother, on the upright bass,
Ryan Paisley on mandolin,
and TJ Lundy on fiddle.
Have I got you all?
>> David Reed: I think so.
>> Clifford Murphy: All right.
[ Applause ]
Enjoy the music, everybody.
[ Music ]
>> All right [inaudible].
>> You all ready?
>> David Reed: Yeah.
[ Music ]
>> Hey.
[ Music and Singing ]
>> We could go all
the way through, too.
[ Music and Singing ]
>> Hugh Campbell: Danny
Paisley, ladies and gentlemen.
[ Applause ]
>> You know the amazing
thing about that song?
You can keep going
as long as you can,
until it took me a get
a string on, you know?
>> David Reed: At least 100 years.
>> Yeah,, darling'
you can't love 140.
>> Yeah [laughter].
>> How's everybody
doing at lunchtime?
Everybody happy?
Well, we're all here trying
to play a little music
in honor of Ola Belle Reed.
I'm sure everyone remembers such
a sweet lady that Dave's mom was.
And they're going to do some songs
that she wrote and some songs
that they recorded, and
some songs we've done.
And we'll just have a big time,
so everybody clap your hands
and have fun, and we'll
proceed for the next few minutes
and play some old-timey
music, all right?
Hugh, you got a tune,
don't you, bud?
>> Hugh Campbell: We do.
We're going to do a tune called
"Don't You Call My Name."
This song was written by
Uncle Herb Campbell way back
in the day, back in the late '60s.
Been record by the likes of the
Johnson Mountain Boys, Del McCoury,
and most recently by
Dailey and Vincent, TJ.
>> Yes.
[ Music and Singing ]
>> Davey.
[ Music ]
[ Applause and Cheering ]
>> That's some good
singing there, Hugh.
>> Hugh Campbell: Thank you.
>> Yeah. Your uncle
wrote that, too, right?
>> Hugh Campbell: Uncle Herb
Campbell, otherwise known as Hub.
>> Hub.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
[ Laughter ]
>> How did he get the name Hub?
Can we ask?
>> Hugh Campbell: No.
>> Probably shouldn't.
>> Dave Reed: All right.
[ Music ]
>> My son, Ryan Paisley,
right there on the mandolin.
[ Applause ]
He'll get us started
off here on this here,
"My Home Across the
Blue Ridge Mountains."
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Oh. Tell them all
about it, Davey.
>> David Reed: He's
waiting for me to talk
and I'm waiting for him to talk.
>> Okay.
>> David Reed: he name of this
song [inaudible], "John Hardy."
Got a question.
How many people can
tell I'm a hillbilly?
Can you tell it?
Why? Because of my size?
Oh, no. "John Hardy," boys.
Here we go.
One, two, three,
[ Music ]
Ryan Paisley.
Go ahead, Ryan, and go for it.
[ Music ]
Give him a hand.
Come on, now.
[ Music ]
Oh, yeah.
TJ's on the other fiddle,
[inaudible].
Yeah. Woo.
Give him a big hand, too.
[ Music ]
Ryan.
TJ, come on, TJ.
Play that fiddle for us.
[ Music ]
That was good.
Thanks. Do it fast now.
>> All right.
[ Music ]
Oh, yeah.
Woo, yeah.
[ Music ]
Come on, TJ.
Get in that microphone there, buddy.
Come on.
[ Music ]
Oh, yeah.
All right.
We're going to end it now, boys.
[ Music ]
[ Applause and Cheering ]
What do you think of them
there hillbilly pickers?
We're the northern
hillbilly pickers.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate that.
You all come back now, hear?
I'm going to shut up.
>> That was David Reed, everyone.
Give David a good hand.
[ Applause and Music ]
We're going to do a
honky-tonk sort of cheating
and loving tune that
his mother wrote.
Ola Belle wrote this
tune [laughter].
And I learned it from
a live recording
that my buddy TJ gave to me.
We recorded it on a record
a number of years ago.
And I believe David's mother,
Ola Belle, and Uncle Alec --
>> David Reed: Yes.
>> -- they recorded it also.
Was it on the New River
Record Label, I believe?
>> David Reed: I think
it was Starday.
>> Starday Recordings.
One of the early --
>> David Reed: One of them.
>> -- bluegrass and
country music record labels.
>> David Reed: One
of them [inaudible].
Yeah, I think so.
>> Honky-tonk sort of thing.
My brother, Michael Paisley,
back here will walk this bass
fiddle on the way through.
>> Yeah, Mike.
Come on, Mike.
>> One, two, three.
[ Music ]
Yes, Kenny.
Oh, yeah. [laughter].
Kenny. Thank you.
>> Hang in there.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
"I'm A-longing for a
Love I'll Never Know."
That's a sort of honky-tonkin' song.
Hugh, how you doing over there?
You're smiling and looking good.
>> Hugh Campbell: I
was trying to hold on.
I'm trying to hang on for dear life
with this world-class
bluegrass band up here.
I'm what you call a -- I've got
sort of a poet kind of a dude.
I can't play to keep up with them.
I'm kind of faking
it is what I'm doing.
But I'm having a good time doing it,
and we're really enjoying
being here.
Everybody's been very nice to us.
Thank you so much, and as soon as
Dave gets in tune here I'm going
to kick off a song I
wrote sometime back.
Are you about ready, are you?
>> David Reed: I'm ready
for Freddie [laughter].
What are we doing?
>> Hugh Campbell: We're going
to do "Footprints Left Below."
>> David Reed: Okay.
>> Hugh Campbell: I wrote this song
about an old man I
knew when I was a boy.
It's about 95% true.
[ Music ]
David.
Dave Reed, ladies and gentlemen.
>> David Reed: Listen to --
[ Music ]
[ Applause and Cheering ]
>> Hugh Campbell.
Thank you.
Thank you, very much.
[ Applause ]
>> David Reed: You
want to stay with him?
You stay with him.
>> I'm allowed to stay with you?
>> David Reed: Yeah, [inaudible].
>> All right.
>> Yes, you will sit.
>> You fellows are going to do a
couple of tunes together, right?
>> Hugh Campbell: Yeah.
>> Yeah.
[ Music ]
>> David Reed: The name of
this next song is "Simple Man."
It's a gospel song I wrote.
And this song, I was
working on the job one day.
I had an idea in my
head and went out.
I normally do the tune first,
but what I did was I
started writing the words.
They started coming real fast.
And I'd like to thank Cliff Murphy
and Doug Peach and Henry Glassie
for allowing this song
to be on there.
It's called "Simple Man."
One, two, three, four, five, six.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you very much there, folks.
Appreciate that.
>> Hugh Campbell: [Inaudible] boy?
So we send this song out to Henry
Glassie, here with his lovely wife,
Aveena [assumed spelling].
Tell me you name.
>> Doug.
>> Hugh Campbell: I know.
Doug Peach [laughter]
Who's that guy?
Send that guy a song [laughter].
>> David Reed: You better
be quiet [inaudible].
>> Hugh Campbell: Cliff Murphy.
The three people involved in
getting this book out to you.
I hope you like it.
>> David Reed: Let's
give them a hand.
[ Applause ]
If it hadn't of been for them,
this wouldn't be happening today.
Thank you.
Stand up. Let everybody see you.
You three.
Come on, stand up.
They're still sitting there.
Get up. Get up.
They want you to stand up.
Come on now.
Yeah. That's -- yeah.
I'm giving you a stand --
I've giving you a standing
ovation even though I look
like I'm sitting down.
>> Hugh Campbell: That's
the big three right there.
>> David Reed: Yeah.
Whoo. Yeah.
I don't know if Cliff liked that.
He's looking at me like oh.
Give credit where credit's due.
[ Music ]
>> Hugh Campbell: Take it, David.
Go ahead, David.
[ Music ]
Dave Reed, ladies and gentlemen.
[ Applause ]
>> Dave Reed: Smile.
[ Music ]
[ Applause and Cheering ]
>> Hugh Campbell: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> That's some fine
singing there, Hugh.
Good job, buddy.
>> Hugh Campbell: Thank you, Danny.
Thank you.
>> As you all can probably see we've
not played a whole lot together.
We rehearsed about two
evenings, didn't we?
>> Hugh Campbell: Yeah, we did.
>> David Reed: About 10 minutes.
>> Yeah [laughter].
>> Hugh Campbell: One hour tops.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, we'd get together and try
to rehearse a little bit
with the [inaudible].
Sat around and reminisced,
didn't we?
>> Yeah.
>> Brian, can you grab
that strap back here?
We're going to feature this
young man here on the mandolin
if I can ever get strung up
here on this [inaudible].
He's 15 years old and he's
been playing bluegrass music
since he was a young, young child.
And he's travelled all around the
United States and Canada with me.
And I think he's becoming one
of the top mandolin players
in the bluegrass music.
That's Ryan Paisley, right there.
Give Ryan a good hand.
[ Applause ]
Ryan Paisley.
>> Good to go.
>> This is the first
bluegrass instrumental wrote
for a mandolin, right?
For Bill Monroe, father
of bluegrass music.
Let's sing blues right
along pretty quick,
but you just back her
down a little bit.
It's only noontime,
all right [laughter]?
>> David Reed: All right.
[ Music ]
>> Hey, oh.
[ Applause ]
>> David Reed: Good job, Ryan.
>> Yeah. This weekend he got to
play on stage with Marty Stuart,
one of the famed country and
bluegrass music mandolin pickers,
and he invited Ryan up
to come and play with him
on his show up in New Jersey.
So that's quite a treat for a young
man like that, I think [inaudible].
We'll do you a tune that
comes out of the mountains
of Southwest Virginia,
Galax, Virginia way.
TJ Lundy's father was Ted Lundy,
and my father was Bob Paisley,
and they played music
together well over 30 years,
and did a lot of recordings
for different [applause]
record companies.
Right across the -- my father was
in Grassy Creek, North Carolina,
right where David's
family, the Campbell's,
moved up to Pennsylvania.
They all moved to the
southeast corner of Pennsylvania
and the northern eastern corner
of Maryland, and a little pocket
of Delaware, right in
that little tri-state area
where they all managed
to come together.
All the families moved up there
and we have such great music
as the Campbell's and the
Reed's and the Miller family.
The Lundy's and the Paisley's
and we could go on and on.
And in our area that
flourish with the --
Sunset Park was an old
country music park.
And New River Ranch
right up in Rising Sun,
they kept everybody entertained
and brought everybody together
on a Sunday afternoon,
and between the music
and the fellowship, to this day --
>> David Reed: Here we are.
>> Here we are [laughter].
Carrying on the tradition,
right [laughter]?
So, we count it as
an honor to be able
to [applause] remember
those days of bygone.
This is a -- back to the song.
"The Old Swinging Bridge."
David, you got it?
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
I believe David's going to
grab his guitar and he's going
to sing a tune I know his
mom used to sing, right?
>> David Reed: Yes, sir.
>> Yes, she did.
Everyone always liked to
hear her sing this tune.
[ Music ]
>> David Reed: It's called
"Tear Down the Fences."
This is one of the
most requested songs.
I don't think this song has gotten
the popularity of maybe like
"On a Mountain," but my wife
and I, we'll go around and sing
in the churches, and they love
this song in the churches.
It's one of the most
requested songs I do.
Just listen to the message.
One, two, three.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Beautiful song right
there, David.
[ Applause ]
Mr. Hugh, I believe you
got something picked
out there, don't you, bud?
>> Hugh Campbell: Yeah, we're
going to do "I've Endured."
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Hugh Campbell: We've been
trying to learn this three
or four different ways, right?
>> There's a bluegrass way,
then there's an old-timey way,
and then there's your
way [laughter].
>> David Reed: It is
the way we [inaudible].
>> Hugh Campbell: I'll tell you why.
>> And today could be even new.
>> David Reed: Yes, it can.
>> So stick with us, folks.
It could be a new song
for all of us.
>> David Reed: Yes, it could.
>> Hugh Campbell: Well,
you know, this song --
the first line in this song is,
"Born in the mountains
50 years ago."
It was written by Ola Belle.
And, of course, that song has
been around for a long time,
but it didn't mean
anything to me, really,
as a 30- and 40-year-old guy.
But when I turned 50, of course, it
started getting a lot more important
to you, you know [laughter].
And for quite a few years
now I've been 50, so --
You know, I'm just going to --
I'm going to do it my way, okay?
I'm just going to launch into it.
>> David Reed: All right.
We'll be right there with you.
>> Hugh Campbell: All right.
>> David Reed: All right.
[ Music and Singing ]
>> Hugh Campbell: David.
[ Music ]
Somebody play it.
[ Applause ]
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
It's a pleasure being here with you.
[ Applause ]
>> David Reed: Do we got
time for the gospel medley?
>> Folks, we've had a good
time, haven't we, everybody?
>> David Reed: I know I have.
>> Yeah [inaudible].
A nice hand for TJ Lundy
on the fiddle right there.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
Ryan Paisley, right
there, on the mandolin.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
Michael Paisley keeping us together
back there on the bass fiddle.
[ Applause ]
And my old buddy, Hugh
Campbell, right there,
doing all them good songs.
That's him.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
And this little rascal right here.
I've known him for a
long, long, long time.
>> David Reed: About a
hundred years isn't it, Danny>
>> That's right.
That's right.
>> David Reed: It's
getting there, ain't it?
>> It's getting there.
Very close aren't we?
David Reed, everyone.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
Sing along with us, all right?
>> David Reed: "I'll Fly Away."
[ Music ]
>> David Reed: Everybody go.
[ Music and Singing ]
>> David Reed: There you go.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> David Reed: Right on the money.
[ Music ]
Everybody now.
[ Music and Singing ]
>> Everybody.
>> David Reed: Everybody sing it.
[ Music and Singing ]
Okay.
[ Music ]
Everyone.
[ Music and Singing ]
Everybody sing real loud, all right?
Hah-hah.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Thanks everyone.
Have a good afternoon.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
>> Elizabeth Peterson:
What do you think?
>> Clifford Murphy: Danny Paisley
and the band, ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you all for coming out.
We've had a great time.
Thank you, Henry, Doug,
Cliff Murphy, and Claudine.
You're beautiful.
>> Elizabeth Peterson: Hugh
Campbell, David Reed, Ryan Paisley,
Michael Paisley, TJ Lundy.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.